i feel like it's a breath of fresh air
south town made it down here boy let me
explain my side of it though he has
posted about wanting approval will he
get that final approval i mean our
company is called creative control you
know what i mean so
that tells you a lot and that right then
in there when i talk to him i let him
know that yo
just have to be told the way it's told
it can't be a kanye commercial you know
so you cannot have any credit control
this is cody right here he shot all the
footage kanye's friends and directors
cootie simmons and chiki oza spent 21
years capturing never-before-seen
footage for genius hitting netflix
february 16th yay didn't just demand
creative control he also reached out to
get a former enemy involved he was
texting me andre because uh drake
said he wanted to narrate the
documentary obviously kaye didn't see
the film he told me when i seen him a
week ago that that's not his process to
watch you know to watch those things but
i feel like if he would have seen the
film he would see why it might not make
sense for drake to narrate him
one time rival jay-z is featured in the
three-part documentary as well as
pharrell but what about hi babe what's
up there's not that much of kim of the
kardashians we see a little bit was
there ever a discussion with them about
sitting down for interviews for this
crew always says say what you always say
about it i'd say if you want to know
more about the kardashians you can watch
them on uh whatever that is the
kardashians
what is shown in the dock is how the
loss of this family member mom danda
seemed to turn a happy-go-lucky kanye
into a more tortured artist definitely
his mom you know losing his mom you know
that
she was his main supporter you know
she was everything she was just rock i
couldn't imagine how that had to feel
and um and in the public eye i would
like to congratulate you on a good job
that you did with me
you look at your daughter you look at
your wife and
how has that fulfilled your life
it's give me a whole perspective an
understanding of what to work for
what to live for even when he had the
house the wife the kids he still had
suicidal thoughts what was it like to
hear him say those things and why was
that important to include i mean it was
important to clue so you understand that
what the journey that he's going through
you know the things that he had to
overcome
don't play
for my children and it's gonna be all
legal
it's gonna be all legal baby he's
posting about his custody stuff and
things he's struggling with are you
worried as his friend i'm not worried at
all because just throughout this whole
journey i seen that that that jesus is
always going to be with kanye when he
had the car accident when he had the
mental breakdown i'm like oh god i got
kanye got it and i and that from that
point i'm like he good regardless but
hopefully with god's blessings
there shouldn't be no way for me to lose
really
you